we've got a lot of jobs we've got a lot
of things that we do in our home when we
have products that actually make it
easier and faster so we can enjoy more
time with the family or being outside
that's exactly what we want and we have
some items that are going to give you
fun this suffer that are going to help
you get in and out a lot quicker and
also items that you know you're going to
say wow who thought of that that is so
cool and I think that that's what we're
going to be talking about with our first
item this is the coquina it's the club
three-in-one cooking sheet today at the
shopping channel and I have tried this
on my barbecue and I can tell you it is
phenomenal have you ever been to a
campsite or to a park where you've got a
barbecue out there that you don't know
who has used it and what's been on it
and it looks nasty well you can take
this sheet with you put it right on the
barbecue and still get grill marks
that's right still get grill marks and
yet you're getting hygiene this is great
for baking sheets for pans for grilling
for cooking for so much more your
cookies your breads your pizzas its
twenty four dollars and ninety-nine
cents and here to tell us more about it
Abby sharp is with us and thank you I'll
come at me thank you so much yeah this
coquina is going to revolutionize how
you cook and grill it's a three-in-one
nonstick grilling and cooking matt goes
on the BBQ like we've got here we can
put it in the oven you can put it on
your baking sheets gonna make everything
so much easier and healthier too because
you don't need to grease things and add
a bunch of oil right so no fats no oil
no fats no ends reusable yes I'm like a
wax paper or a cooking paper that you
would throw out after you use it you
wash it and keep going now look at this
it's a hundred and fifty centimeters
long just I mean oh you could just go on
forever and so the lovely thing about
this is you cut it to fit the unique
unique surface you're trying to cover
okay so we all different sized grills we
all have different sizes super duper BBQ
you can cut it this is be an amazing
barbecue but you could get a barbecue
won a cooking sheet in an oven guard out
of one sheet okay so I want to start
with the grill because you know fathers
days on the way and we're thinking about
barbecuing of course and you know one of
the number one things people ask me
about when it comes to barbecuing it's
just even say
flake it's kind of strange put something
on fun together catch on fire is it
going to be leaching things into my food
absolutely not it is FDA approved up to
550 degrees and unlike a lot of other
nonstick cookware which you know has a
sling called PF OA s and that has some
environmental concerns to it this is PF
way free it's actually made with a
unique nonstick cooking material that
doctors and surgeons use inside the body
Wow to create like valves when they're
doing heart surgery oh my gosh oh it's
severe enough for that you know it's
safe to be cooking on so I've got I'm
just going to throw some some banana
down I've got some pineapple on the
grill honey going on you're putting
honey on that but no yeah like why not
we're going to do a little breakfast
brunch on the grill and you can imagine
you're putting honey right onto the
grill okay that's going to make a big
old mess you're not going to want to
have to clean up that but with the
Kachina you just wipe it clean a little
warm soapy water and it's good as you
know now what I love is that you get the
grill marks still that's okay you know
you put it on an in it and it saves you
having to scrub and you know go at your
BBQ that's the big thing it's like I
don't have time to be scrubbing and
scraping when I've got guests over who
I'd love to be able to actually enjoy my
time with and look at this I'm gonna
throw down some coconut definitely can't
do that on a normal girl came out on the
grid normally obviously I would just go
right down the greats right but with the
Kachina you actually can you can pull
that off and i always find even when i'm
grilling vegetables I'll lose half them
down the greats right right you actually
enjoy it and then it's just one map that
you you rinse off after you're done yet
warm soapy water it doesn't carry
flavors it doesn't carry odors which is
really important if let's say you're
cooking fish and then you would like to
do like a dessert afterwards or
cross-contamination we have friends who
are vegetarians and they don't want
their you know their their their
vegetables touching the same area of the
of the grill is the meat ok so it's
reversible it's reusable this will last
you have the grill marks still but yet
you see how easy this is going to be to
clean so if it is fatty if it is greasy
if it is you know charring on girls you
need all the barbecue sauces or as you
did honey
money and that's the thing when it comes
to Charing as a dietitian that's like
I'm concerned about because I don't want
that trying to to cause costs
carcinogens in the bottom right and
that's what it does so this is going to
totally cut down on the risk of those
flare-ups which can be carcinogen there
do your steaks on there do your french
toast your bananas with honey your
pineapple on your coconut you can do it
all and also you can work in the in the
oven as well I mean I always I do a lot
of baking at home and I love baking pies
I tend to over fill them admittedly and
then you get a big mess on the bottom of
your oven so I want to show you because
let's say I made a pie I just put this
you cut it to fit again put it on the
bottom rack okay look at this big mess
that I've got going I do and I do mice
my raspberry off of our pies could you
imagine having to scrape that off the
bottom of your oven or worse yet you put
the oven on self clean and clean you
smell it Oh higher how that is the worst
that is the worst but look at this
little warm soapy water and it literally
just comes right off so easy you're not
scrubbing you're not scraping you get to
spend that time with your family and
friends and enjoying your pie not
worried about ruining any of your dishes
you know worried about the big mess on
the bottom of the oven that could cause
fires later on and vote layer up later
on as it's burning that's right that's
what I I mean that's always a big
concern with me when you're just stick
it in there wash it off and it's going
to be good to go to snow and it actually
can go in the dishwasher as well if
that's alone that you would dance for i
also want to quickly show you this we've
got some quesadillas cuz i love mexican
night my home mmm but let's be honest if
you're trying to cut down on fat you're
probably not going to try to grease that
pan or you want to bake things so that
you're not pan frying look at all that
stuck on your quesadillas going to get
stuck to your pan and you're good to
wrestle with it to try to get it off but
with the kokino like look at this one
easy peasy and it just lists right off
that simple that easy and now I'm not
worried about that baked on caked on chi
o the cookie sheet exactly this is the
kind of baking sheet that you would have
to soak then scrub then put in the
dishwasher you can fight as well buy a
new baking sheet
I've done that a few times in Italy now
we've done all kinds of things on the
Kachina today you know from the ribs to
the french toast to the burgers you know
I'm gonna steal a CO yes to the cookies
and even cooking without burning on the
bottom just you get really even
distribution okay and I love that
because again it doesn't carry that
flavor in color and odor so let's say
you wanted to make a meatloaf or fish
dinner for your family and then you want
to bake a batch of cookies you just wipe
it clean and your cookies and hooker to
smell like like fish or the meat that
you're preparing and you can use it over
and over and over and over again I love
it for the BBQ many of us out there have
done our barbecuing and we get you know
the nastiness on there well definitely
take advantage of this and a great gift
idea to if you know somebody who has a
cottage or you know you go to their
backyard pool a lot and you're always
over there at their house get them this
so that when they're doing the grilling
it makes their job a lot easier thank
you so yeah thank you for how do you
Lily wow what a great tip all right I'm
going to go